Okay, I'm back
Wha..? How did I die!?
(Suspicious Bob giggles)
What happened to me?
Did you do that?
(Bob's laughter)
I'm dead too.
What did you--?
Oh, you've got grenades
Ooooooooh
I did not get grenades. I gotta show you what I discovered.
It's f***ing awesome
Ok..let's restart...
I did not kill us
uh huh
I, caused us to be killed
But, I did not do it
Okay...
Alright, so, so, okay, so
We're just hanging out
Yeah
And I was like: Haha! He talks when you shoot him.
Uh huh
Right? Right? Watch this
D'oh-oh geez
why am I watching this? hang on
it's coming
Oh, my balls
come on motherfucker i'm waiting for
this
It just does it!
You dick!
oh my god your arm blew off! my arm blew off?
Oh god! Holy fucking shit you don't have arms! I went in side mode
oh what have you done?! OOHHH GODDD!
Talk to the man we got to get outside! I gotta drink some water and fix this shit!
oh god! Jesus Christ! Wait, look at me on the ground. (weird sounds)
Wait, why are you down?
I was bleeding out. I... I have no arms you dick!
Jesus! Hang on, I need water first, hang on.
Oh there that's all better!
Wooh!
I feel good!
Mark: Oh man, this game is amazing! Bob: That is awesome
alright, this game 10/10 game of the year.
Hello everybody my name is Markiplier
And, welcome back to Blood and Bacon with Bob
so... hi Bob!
Hi everybody!
This game Bob: It's so good Mark: I... I'm actually not lying I love this game.
for people to see the footage of me
accidentally actually discovering that
easter egg while you were gone. we need to... there was like an electrical box yeah over here
electric fence? oh (Sudden realization)... oh cool! Bob: One of us can go in there? That definitely won't kill me.
Bob: One of us can go in there? That definitely won't kill me.
ok you want me.. you want me to do the thing
let's try it try it. Neat! nice i wonder
if it kills me if I walk through it
oh my god it doesn't. Nice! why is that ? ok are we gotta get to the next level
there's 30 days in this game we want
people want to see progress people want
to see us to make it through this game
and do it well with skill that is not
why people watch my videos I can say
that with authority
ok that's absolutely not what people
expect from me
oh my god is he gonna kill us for the
flashlights ignite I i highly doubt that
do something us old is not there's no
way
look you go kill the pig zombie so we
can progress i'll just keep doing this
ok alright then by the way also there's
gonna be no pigs until you get out here
so get them it might as well carry on
with this mission
ok ok oh my god it's fucking pitch black
out there
yeah it's night now ok but if you would
just just grenades us for anything that
we did ever
I mean that was great very well you know
what your energy wound
what are some of these are skeletons
described distract them to describe them
in I'll just kill them all right getting
the beer thing I think the thing
hell yeah oh oh oh oh my god is that
what just oh jeez oh god what rumbled
nothing who I got an explosion
okay we gotta keep like he said we gotta
keep about all almost got it
wait oh you know what I'm keeping a body
part in the air
well
boy o almost there almost there it's too
high
oh yeah fireworks do you know where is
that it's up in the air
I did it I did it by shooting body parts
up in the air and I see it you weapon
okay well how'd you get a body part up
in the air you gotta shoot it you gotta
shoot a piece of it you gotta get a
piece the showpiece ok make sure your
bullets full of ammo or a gun whatever
and ensure your full bullet and mouth
okay then just kind of like well gotta
do geez that's harder than I got how
yeah how many times you have to do it i
can only get a few before like its way
that far away that there's like a
counter you gotta like I forget how i
did it like it must have been a better
body part in this like the head maybe
yeah yeah that's it the head works
better
so you just gotta get it up and then
there's like a counter that starts oh
yeah i saw that got this one
I'm on it I'm on it I'm on it at this
secant almost there is taking more than
the last time
yeah we oh yeah yeah yeahs this this
world is weird but also did you notice
that that up grain silo in the distance
over there with the mound on the side of
the penis
oh yeah oh yeah
there's something at the top of it is a
key at the top of it
why don't we get up there a good
question must be aware stand on my head
that that's not a thing you can do
ok there's got to be a legit can you
shoot the thing off the top doubted
there's a platform there so obviously
there's got to be like a weapon that can
rocket jump or something that would make
rockets
oh wow wow said rocket job till I got my
mind went to rockets okay i'm gonna talk
again what tomorrow is going to be a day
that you don't want to miss he said we
should use that grounder you gotta use a
grounder don't get on grindr find local
singles in your area with grindr this
the grinder that you gotta get the
farmers only version of grindr crossing
the highway is the hopefully what would
blow my god is this thing i have
unlimited ammo
oh my god it does what it needs no reef
what this amazing i want this is the
best gun ever so also we get grenades
now apparently Rambo style what did he
say Rambo style he said he put explosive
ammo and all the weapons or something
oh really why how do i use the grenade
one the one button
whoa oh my god oh god oh god this is
revenge day
oh yeah is that white oh yeah these
don't need reload even the AK is like
this only not reloading revolver
oh my god this is outstanding
this is next-level gore if it because
I'm an idiot if it
this is a where's the other are you
there are is just around him
got it revenge day comes once a week
oh boy does it ever wait i wonder if we
can
I'm gonna chop down the silo by shooting
it that's a good idea
I'm
sure that'll work maybe I gotta shoot up
shoot a pig piece up there
wait there's no there's no key up there
anymore what was it only available that
day know how we supposed to I don't know
this Martian why don't you know this
shit i'm an idiot I didn't finish
engineering school that's why that what
you wanted to hear
I actually was fishing for that yeah
well you got what you wanted
are you hurts everybody markiplier is an
idiot
well i'm getting a sick combo on this
thing
mobile not up with no reload required
the shoot something up into the air
situation is pretty easy
I'm helping I'm helping I'm helping you
literally just hold down the left mouse
on the AK and sort of wave at it could
get like I'm not even really aiming at
it and i'm still getting hits on it
no I'm doing it I'm also helping we're
at work together on this
oh it's probably mostly you that because
i'm seriously like not even really
aiming at that much well I want I play
to win so you need to get your game
together
there we go 708 these fiji all right
let's get to the next day I said world
record that is a new world record
so you are aware of the pitch work yeah
well I would be shocked if he wasn't
that mean he just started
it's just that's how it is so you know I
just figured he that's because he looks
down like why am I on a wall
oh god here
oh no and then he instantly dies like he
forgot he was supposed to die
Oh check out the reload action on this
revolver
ok most effective i drop the course I
don't know why I expected there to be
both of who we just get a side action
oh I create bullets yeah hey hey you
like you like my gun like my guns heat
hehe
he did yes that's right in that spot
where my penis used to be
yeah yeah I'm not doing anything doing
that what you do are you doing that you
side of your mix these these
interactions emotion about it
yep hey hey hey there's a way out of
this
alright I'm already dead so I feel like
this is kind of loose lose weight so if
i do this yellow line
oh but I do this what I miss me blush
I got one you can't die hang on all
right okay ready
line it up line it up oh look my balls
ok when I actually vomited blood and
then just grenades at me whoo dude whoa
what-what there was a there was a dark
souls praise the Sun symbol is he
singing the guy when the mom saying us
to sleep when I oh no that's going on
but i love it i wanna walk slowly around
as he's his head tracks me around this
bar and quickly while he's singing
there's also there's also a skull up
here I don't know what it's for
there's an outline of skull up there
there the praise of something was up
there
yeah she's yeah oh gee what
no I'm not going back there that look
through this with method or we get this
next one we gotta take a careful look
around this place because there's some
secrets out here and oh boy
alright why is it this color outside
because i have pushed the button i shot
the button i'm going to turn the
electric fence on before they all start
travel around and im gonna gather him to
gather them up
I got him don't remember coming for me
my god
don't worry I'm black mass blasting all
of them nowhere last him I got him right
I'm not there yet beyond its fun
there we go that's some fried piggies
there see ya guys
these ashen oh my god not at all dead
layer not so we need I need health drink
some water
they seem to be doing a lot more damage
than they have been if I'm a skeleton
and drinking this water gave you your
arms back all the way
shouldn't this water like bring me back
to life theoretically speaking but I'm
assuming it assumes that you're not dead
considering you're walking around the
water is making assumptions about me and
that's why it's racing it's a very
judgmental water to be honest the tail
I don't want to scare you but I think
things are going to get a little bit
more tough on you
Oh start crying oh oh jeez things are
going to get more tough on us
did you talk to him yeah I talk to him
okay oh why were you doing something I
was just looking around I thought we
were
oh that's right I said that around oh I
said we should look at our surroundings
more closely so let's go next I ball but
she's i'm an idiot i apologize for our
redo it
yeah uh-huh oh jesus what is it I don't
know I was bigger
oh my god they're big all their big oh
they got big hotel ass blowed they do
another don't you just died
yeah they don't ask blowed whoa hey
oh god oh my god I'm gonna get some
health fellow is baby how big they are
they fucking come out of nowhere yeah
that was a biggie
holy shit well why did I wonder away
from the health water i'm gonna i'm
gonna try to shove one of these big
animals inside
I don't know G oh my god they do ask
load yeah
oh ok ok
oh boy you should come get some liquid
I'm okay
oh my god I'm not okay how do I am i
dying
what I was just dying help may I'm
coming
I the pic was dead and I was pushing it
and it was just like who you're doing no
well maybe you shouldn't have done that
maybe maybe I was trying to push him
into the thing is it like if you touch
the tusks when you're pushing it hurts
you
Oh what whoa-oh
what whoa that is weird like if you
touch them on the front it hurts you
well that's not what I wanted I got a
grenade sorry sorry okay I'm gonna look
around
Michonne easy shit thing
come here you big motherfucker we well
but there was another Sun symbol over
here just but it doesn't do anything if
you shoot it
maybe it doesn't work because the other
Sun symbol is already shot i want to
know how the pigs go all upon who
there's another Sun symbol in here too
oh dude it while I can't believe you
found that target
oh ok look up this is a game of many
mysteries and also some drugs
yeah so why didn't this one work oh it's
just wanted the door there it bounds a
real hard
ok so there's got to be a bunch of like
hidden symbols like that right right
yeah sure yeah okay I can't find
anything
whoa what just went flying in the air oh
is that you little pig leg
ok alright if we want to find secrets i
guess we could read a guide
now that's for jerks ok well we got
graphics are you gonna find things now
let's just going to trigger the next
don't trigger me ready of triggered
ready got triggered don't do it okay
apparently we're going to see something
completely new tomorrow like pigs amies
yeah fucked up right zombies
listen we use my psychopathic powers to
the door for you
psychopathic I don't think those are the
right words but we're let me use my
cycle path hours open that door for you
through this is didn't rack that's
offensive is really offensive what
psychopathic people
yeah don't they have worse problems that
me making out of touch feel about them
in Psychopaths know what is happening
why did i get around fifty percent of my
health
why the heck and I kill these
butterflies because although hey yeah
there's little pigs
it's little things that keep running in
and out of my line of sight is like out
of the matter how its little bigs get
dead little big
hello please well they're so fast
but they're weak Wow
Jesus they're getting faster we get
faster than less than shit I don't know
but I'm hurt oh god oh god okay thank
you
oh right there trying trying man trying
to we're done I guess
oh sweet alright let's get through day
ten I bet there's a boss that day 10
hopefully my name blurry men and I care
what you all by the way that son on the
little red building it it just made a
sound when you hit ok we haven't bad
absolutely been using only my pistol for
almost this entire thing I mean that
revolvers pretty good nice cocking
action on it
great cocking action is quite a kak can
I can't stop looking in the sky
yeah i know-oh-oh started
mark can we close the door can we undo
whatever you do do not think we can
oh wow you want to be treated as we can
okay god no cheese for girls
ok holy shit gr8 wait stop bro stop you
don't know nothing
well this seems bad uh I'll what if you
all staying here or used in here one of
us like peek out my god oh my god its
head follows you
oh my god i was like oh my god man just
wait what just gonna keep on talking
what shelf my big fat hair until you
shoot me gal gotten to die now bra but
now got a long kay and us it's about
intelligent he's invisible now holding
shit oh my god this is derek mark mark
Skinner he states stay close to me he's
here he's always going to you might see
all got here maybe they're making
alright i go to the center going to the
center Laurel to the center
yeah I'll you know it is open because
you know the feeling
what does that sound like the farmer no
okay he's coming to me get ready with
the electrical he's coming to me you
could not everybody all right tell me
why tell me why i dunno ogz well we're
going on
okay that was good though got rid of the
smaller pigs I'm gonna try and lure him
here i'll stay here we're coming down
from or he's coming towards me always
coming to me
oh he was right there dude did I get him
know we didn't get her mind about
keeping them up we can see where he is
when the electric fences giggling are
you hurt you are going for to wear it
comfortably he's close to the middle i
am driving about drug
Oh chasing me and a circle around the
house
okay he's coming to me maybe lighten up
10 all you missed it
administrator out of order it says out
of order we only get so many uses of it
for tonight and you fold
whoa if you should have any s ask does
something always got like electric shit
is that
whoa that's King oh he's doing something
only one angry we will show angry his
ass got blasted off what he's healing
what he's yelling huh haha oh very scary
very scary who very scary
you need to shoot his ass bone yeah his
is because I'm gonna do is I'm gonna get
more ammo
it's a grenade or something okay all
right xxx-ok grenade was going to 10 I'm
down I'm down I'm down
alright i had a drive away how well he
said he was pleased you
he's nothing but hitting me on the
ground 0 gie I gotta thank you got your
friend gonna go go go you only have full
health
nice he's not to be trusted parking ok I
got getting her dad I'm getting grenades
got great talk to dick
oh I missed on that one lighten up his
is good
whoa hurry it's that ass blasted me as a
damaged
oh ya blasted right knee and
he's coming for always liked you best
come install the melody yeah he needs to
clean himself by pressing the tea but
are you what are you at health right now
yeah I'm healing up loon everybody's
right here
oh oh my god he did his thing again I
gotta get going to get more ammo healing
up we need a lot more we should have
been feel I pistol yeah we should have
been feeling this thing up because wolf
hello
oh geez because it like has a reservoir
of blood from the previous rounds or
something oh so it's like filled up all
the way right now
oh geez he lost more pieces of himself
but he's really going after me I gotta
go he'll i'll try and a groom
I can't believe strategy is a part of
this this game is amazing by the way
don't hear you motherfucker you can only
ask lesson with your fiscal know the the
other gun works i believe I'm not
getting any ass blaster shots with my AK
well a matter happening anymore he was
getting lots of ass but I don't know
it's just not working it's just not
working right now
oh it's got a Scholastic Oh help ya
think he has a new assblaster . because
he lost something in the water like you
are so it's yeah
mm oh that's happy oh and he's done he's
done he's done busy
no wait yes yeah yeah yeah fuckin fuckin
all day yeah alright no 10 legodi
vibrant flame
okay can we get them into the grinder no
I don't we can break like part of them
off
ya gotta really well on that spine there
or maybe not maybe this is just the
satisfaction thing
yeah that's our that's not working okie
alright so that was great we did it we
that's only date and game completed game
not completed yet maybe our play through
this completed for now maybe that's one
more let us know because this game is
wild but thank you everybody so much for
watching thanks for being here
any wise words thanks it's scary
yeah so they're in this video but i have
gone up stay down here